the team at pugs is excited to simplify
the development of
their conversational experience using
dialogflow cx
stick around to see it all in action
hi i'm priyanka vergaria and in this
episode of deconstructing chat bots
we will help our friends at pugs create
a conversational experience for their
customer support
using dialogflow cs before we dive into
the console though
let's lay out our use case requirements
first
we know that most of their user requests
are to order dog shoes
so it makes sense to start with the
order flow first
in this flow we want to collect order
information from the user
including the size and the color of the
shoes and then present a confirmation
if the user confirms we end the flow and
if they want to edit the order
then we gather the new size and color
from them and then place the order
now that we know what we are building
let's head to dialogflow cx console the
easiest way is to get there from the
documentation
create a new project make sure you
enable billing and the dialogflow api
then we go back into the dialogflow cx
console and click on the project we just
created
it prompts us to create an agent that's
exactly what we want to do
we name it select the location where we
want it
it and the time zone and the language
and we're good to create now notice that
within a project we can create
multiple agents we have our default
start flow
with our start page which comes with the
default welcome intent
so let's go ahead and test it at this
point
all it does is greets the user we want
to create a transition route
from the start page that leads to the
order flow
create new intent let's name it and add
some training phrases
let's add some basic ones such as i
would like to place an order
but we also need to add some specific
phrases with color
let's add i want to buy green shoes for
my pub
as soon as we add that that notice that
the color parameter
automatically gets created with sis dot
color entity type
and this color parameter will be stored
in the session for us to access in other
pages
also since the user has already provided
the color
our agent will not ask for that
information
providing a more natural experience
now let's add another example with the
size
i want to get large shoes for my husky
now we see that the large is not
automatically identified as a parameter
because size is unique to pugs use case
so let's fix that but before we do that
add a transition to new page
where we will collect information and
save it
let's go into manage entity types and
then create
new name it size and add small
medium large size in there with some
synonyms
now while we are on the manage tab let's
go into the intent to see if we can add
our size parameter now
add one or two more examples with both
sides and color to add some variety
let's head over to our collect
information page and add the entry
dialog
to let the user know that we will
collect some more information now
then add the parameter size is a
required parameter and if a user does
not provide it
we want to prompt them with the
fulfillment here
we repeat the same for color as well
with that
we are ready to define our transition
routes from this page
and in this case we don't need to
trigger an intent all we need
is to make sure our parameters are
filled in
so we look for the condition to match
page.paramster status
equals final once all the parameters are
defined
and collected which means both size
and color in this case that's when the
status will turn to final
this is also where we can match other
conditions such as
if the parameter parameter.colors equals
red
then send to a sorry page because that
color is not available in the inventory
once the status equals final condition
is met we would route the user to the
new confirmation page
in the confirmation page let's first add
the entry dialog to share
what they have selected to buy we can
access the parameters
in the session by using the dollar sign
we don't have
any parameter to add for this page for
the transition
routes we want to have a yes and a no
route
for yes path let's create a new intent
and call it confirmation.yes and provide
a few training phrases that indicate
yes save the intent and then add the
transition page
as success do the same thing for no
route
success page is easy at this point all
we need to do
is add a nice entry dialog for the
transition route add true in the
condition
to force and select end flow as the
transition page
now the failure page we want to see if
the user wants to change their selection
or they just don't want to buy today for
that we add the entry dialog
and then add the transition routes if
they say no
we just want to add a goodbye page quite
simple
but if they say yes then we send them
back to the start of the flow to make
their color
and size selections now let's test it
that doesn't quite work and that's
because the parameters are already
filled we need to clear up the
parameters before the state
changes to the start page and we do that
in the parameter presets in the yes
intent transition
of the failure page let's test it again
and we see that the flow is
all set all right so that was a lot
we created the entire order flow from
scratch by creating a bunch of pages
we also learned how intense parameters
and entities work in conjunction with
the pages
i am very excited for the next episode
where we will extend the pugs
conversational experience
further by adding multiple flows until
then
i look forward to seeing your thoughts
on this episode in the comments below
you